palpitations déçoit j'ai l'impression de
verifone rappellent qu'ils arrêtent pas
de tourner depuis longtemps marie-eve
lapierre connaît les symptômes d'une
crise d'anxiété et l'essai de gérer son
stress
mais c'est éprouvant depuis la mi mars
la première fois que je suis sorti à
l'épicerie en début dé but pandémie puis
que j'ai vu les tables de vis que les
gens avaient leurs paniers pleins et
puis tout ce mois ça m'a fait qu'à voter
parce que je me suis fait beaucoup
beaucoup de scénarios dans la tête comme
on aurait pu nourriture qu'ils
s'envoyaient dans un mois j ai suivi au
privé puis j'ai eu de rendez vous annulé
à cause de la pandémie parce qu'on fait
plus respectées du web
marie-eve a trouvé du soutien virtuel
tout le monde souhaite m'entendre et
l'organisme revivre a rapidement mis sur
pied du soutien en ligne depuis bientôt
30 ans il aide les personnes avec des
troubles anxieux dépressifs ou
bipolaires
c'est toutes les certitudes qui entoure
le contexte qui est excessivement
difficile particulièrement pour des gens
déjà vulnérables au niveau de la santé
mentale
ce qui m'inquiète c'est que s'il
accordait 19 a été un tremblement terre
on mesure mal le tsunami que vrai de la
résurgence de problèmes de santé mentale
les demandes auprès de revivre ont
augmenté du tiers depuis avril de
grandes entreprises ont fait appel à ses
services
c'est le cas de ssq assurance pour près
de 2000 employés qui sont en télétravail
qu'on voyait dans le monde qu'est ce qui
se passe et les pas que la pandémie
avait sur la santé psychologique des
gens et on voulait pas trinquer destine
comme des ailes
notre pic si vous voulez en santé
mentale et en psychiatrie c'est
actuellement dans le fond qu'on lui fait
actuellement kill kill début les
déconfinement lève le voile sur l'
isolement des gens vulnérables pendant
plusieurs semaines ces patients-là ont
souffert en silence et maintenant donc
il ya un appel à l'aide qui viennent
leur part si on se fait ce qui est
arrivé en asie cette année ce qui est
arrivé en europe notamment
on sait qu'habituellement le pic de
consultation pour ce qui touche la santé
mentale et la psychiatrie ça va vraiment
plus se produire
qu'on commence de confinement à
l'inconnu s'est ajoutée la durée du
confinement
les pertes d'emplois les deuils les
tensions conjugales les effets de l'
isolement et les sécurités affecte au
grand nombre de personnes quand ça fait
dix onze douze semaines
rey après le week-end de pâques on a
commencé à avoir un changement est là il
y avait une fatigue psychique qui
s'installe et les besoins santé mentale
vont durer nettement plus longtemps que
la pandémie elle-même
on n'a pas fini de mesurer l'impact de
cette pandémie sans précédent qui touche
aussi la santé mentale un aspect dont on
a beaucoup parlé mais qui souffre d'un
manque chronique de service ici anne
louise despatie radio canada montréal